[Música]
después de convertirse en el presidente
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos que vi macarthy enfrenta
varios desafíos el republicano tuvo que
dar concesiones a su propio partido para
poder recibir su apoyo
Gustavo Petro visitó nuevamente
Venezuela el mandatario colombiano fue
recibido en Caracas por su homólogo
Nicolás Maduro días después de la
reapertura total de los pasos
fronterizos comunes traemos reporte
desde la capital venezolana
la región colombiana de nariño celebró
con música y danza el famoso carnaval de
negros y blancos catalogado como
patrimonio cultural y material de la
humanidad por la UNESCO y en la que se
conmemora la liberación de los Esclavos
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos la actividad en el
congreso ya puede empezar después de que
el republicano Kevin mccarthy finalmente
lograra el apoyo de su propio partido
para ser presidente de la cámara de
representantes un retraso histórico que
ha ido acompañado de importantes
concesiones a la extrema derecha
concesiones que marcarán la actividad de
la cámara baja lluis Muñoz con más
detalles sobre los retos que enfrentará
mccarthy
por lo tanto el honorable Kevin mccarthy
del estado de California habiendo
recibido la mayoría de los votos
emitidos es debidamente elegido
presidente de la cámara de
representantes
representantes sí pero a qué costo
macarthy necesitó 15 votaciones para
reunir el apoyo de su propio partido no
pasaba esto desde antes de la guerra
civil de Estados Unidos sin embargo él
mismo lo ve como un asunto de
resiliencia
Puede que no les conozca a todos algunos
de ustedes son nuevos pero espero que
una cosa quede Clara después de esta
semana nunca me rindo
diferente lo ve el profesor de la
Universidad de Nueva York Emilio viano
en France 24 retrató un panorama
complicado para el nuevo presidente
está muy debilitado sufrió la
humillación de 14 rondas durante semanas
el alamas a la extrema derecha del
partido republicano ha estado
presionando para obtener concesiones por
lo que la presidencia no le ha salido
barata a macarce entre la concesiones
más importantes que ha hecho mccarthy a
los Rebeldes para ser elegido es que
cualquier diputado puede instar una
moción de censura para destituir al
presidente de la cámara lo que debilita
mucho su posición con esto el ala Ultra
conservadora del partido republicano
presionará para dificultar el acuerdo en
el techo de deuda con los demócratas así
como para iniciar investigaciones y
comisiones que marquen agenda lejos de
las políticas moderadas por lo que el
reto final de macarthy será luchar
contra su propio destino y evitar ser
una marioneta en otras noticias de
Estados Unidos el presidente Joe biden
realizará este domingo su primer viaje a
México como motivo de la Cumbre de
líderes de América del Norte y el tema
principal del encuentro sin duda será la
migración antes de aterrizar en la
capital el mandatario visitará la ciudad
fronteriza de El Paso en Texas cerca de
donde se ha visto la masiva llegada de
personas que buscan cruzar a territorio
estadounidense su viaje Se dará pocos
días después de presentar el nuevo plan
con el que prevé de volver a México a
migrantes irregulares provenientes de
Venezuela Cuba Nicaragua y Haití
y ayuda a tonos inmigrantes los buenos
somos más presidentes como ven en El
Paso somos una comunidad muy acogedora
somos una comunidad que se basa en la
amistad que se basa en la migración ser
del paso significa literalmente ser del
pasado el paso se llama el paso del
Norte a las partes del Norte y la
migración y la comprensión de las
personas que pasan por nuestra comunidad
para trabajar por una vida mejor para
buscar una vida mejor es algo que está
arraigado en nuestro ADN aquí cambiamos
de tema y vamos a Venezuela donde se
llevó a cabo una reunión imprevista
entre el presidente Nicolás maduro y su
homólogo colombiano Gustavo Petro es el
segundo encuentro entre ambos
mandatarios que se lleva a cabo en
territorio venezolano desde que Petro
llegó al poder en agosto del año pasado
y tras reestablecer sus relaciones
diplomáticas desde Caracas nuestra
corresponsal Daniela Zambrano con los
detalles
luego de esta reunión que se prolongó
durante tres horas en el Palacio de
Miraflores y que fue convocada a última
hora se emitió un comunicado conjunto en
el que se ratifica la postura del
gobierno de Nicolás maduro de respaldar
al gobierno de Colombia en La Búsqueda
del cc al fuego bilateral y la paz total
con la guerrilla del eln esto ocurre
pocos días después del impase entre el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro y la guerrilla
luego que el propio presidente anunciara
públicamente un cese al fuego bilateral
que se prolongaría durante seis meses y
tres días después el propio eln lo
desmintiera llamó la atención que
avanzaba esta reunión y minutos antes de
que culminara llegó al palacio de
Miraflores el general César Martínez
quien ha sido el representante de
Nicolás maduro ante los diálogos de paz
en el comunicado también se habla de
avances en materia comercial en la
reapertura de los puentes fronterizos no
hubo declaraciones a la prensa tras el
encuentro por el contrario mucho
hermetismo estuvieron presentes por
parte del gobierno colombiano el
canciller Álvaro Leiva el embajador de
Colombia en Unidos Luis Murillo y el
embajador de Colombia en Venezuela
Armando Benedetti así como el ministro
de comercio por parte del gobierno de
Nicolás maduro estuvieron presentes la
primera damacilia flores la
vicepresidenta delsy Rodríguez y el
recién designado canciller de Venezuela
y van Gil quien previamente sostuvo un
encuentro con Armando Benedetti
posterior al encuentro en Miraflores el
presidente Gustavo Petro fue recibido
por Armando Benedetti en su residencia
se espera que el mandatario colombiano
viaje este 8 de enero a Chile para un
encuentro bilateral con su homólogo
Gabriel boricci dos trenes subterráneos
chocaron en el norte de Ciudad de México
las autoridades confirmaron que hay al
menos un muerto y decenas de personas
resultaron heridas desde la capital
mexicana nuestro corresponsal Mario
carbonell nos trae más detalles
pasadas las nueve de la mañana de este
sábado ocurrió un accidente en el
sistema de transporte colectivo metro de
la Ciudad de México en la línea 3 entre
las estaciones Potrero y la raza en
dirección a Indios Verdes hacia el norte
de la ciudad la jefa de gobierno de la
ciudad Claudia sheinbaum no se
encontraba en la capital del país al
momento del accidente ella estaba por
iniciar un acto político en el Estado de
Michoacán al saber de la situación se
regresó vía aérea a la ciudad para dar
seguimiento a las investigaciones
peritos de la Fiscalía de la Ciudad de
México ya se encuentran trabajando para
determinar la causa exacta de este
accidente el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador vía Twitter ha expresado
sus condolencias por la persona que
hasta el momento ha perdido la vida y se
mantiene atento al seguimiento de esta
situación sobre todo por la salud de los
de los heridos que están insisto siendo
atendidos en distintas clínicas de
hospitales de la capital del país
en medio de su segunda crisis tras
asumir el cargo el presidente chileno
Gabriel Boris anunció la renuncia de su
ministra de Justicia Marcela Ríos su
dimisión se dio después de que partidos
de oposición protestaran por los
indultos otorgados en diciembre a 13
personas condenadas por el estallido
social en 2019 y por los que amenazaron
con presentar una acusación
constitucional en contra de ríos en su
reemplazo estará Luis Cordero Vega
y terminamos en Colombia con el carnaval
de negros y blancos que reúne cada año a
miles de personas en la región andina de
nariño catalogado como patrimonio
cultural y material de la humanidad por
la UNESCO del carnaval es una de las
fiestas más importantes de Colombia
veamos un día de negro otro de blanco en
Colombia el carnaval de negros y blancos
es un momento de mezcla cultural para
celebrar la liberación de los Esclavos
así como la unidad es una de las fiestas
más importantes del país ofrece un
espectáculo colorido el festival se
celebra cada mes de enero y atrae a
miles de personas a las calles de San
Juan de pasto en el sur de Colombia
salimos en familia y lo que hacemos Es
disfrutar
esto es una fiesta inclusiva
es reconociendo toda nuestra cultura y
nuestros ancestros bueno Nosotros
siempre estos carnavales los utilizamos
para divertirnos para iniciar un año
nuevo con alegría con entusiasmo con
mucha esperanza este Carnaval que
funciona las tradiciones españolas
africana indígena de Colombia pretende
contribuir a romper las fronteras
raciales y ayudar a derribar Las
barreras culturales de ahí el nombre de
blanco y negro de los dos últimos días
del carnaval durante el primer día los
blancos se pintan la cara de negro para
celebrar la liberación de los Esclavos y
al día siguiente todos se visten y se
maquillan de blanco tolerancia y
respecto son los valores que quiere
transmitir esta fiesta declarada
patrimonio de la humanidad por la UNESCO
hasta que este Informativo en frases 24
Gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos a
que continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]